YUFENG GUO: On this
episode of AI Adventures,
find out what Kaggle
Kernels are and how to get
started using them.
Though there's no
popcorn in this episode,
I can assure you that
Kaggle Kernels are popping.
Kaggle is a platform for doing
and sharing data science.
You may have heard about
some of their competitions,
which often have cash prizes.
It's also a great place
to practice data science
and learn from the community.
Kaggle Kernels are
essentially Jupyter Notebooks
in the browser that can be
run right before your eyes,
all free of charge.
Let me say that again in case
you missed it, because this
is truly quite amazing.
Kaggle Kernels is
a free platform
to run Jupyter Notebooks
in your browser.
This means that you
can save yourself
the hassle of setting
up a local environment
and have a Jupyter
Notebook environment
right inside your browser
anywhere in the world
that you have an
internet connection.
Not only that-- the processing
power for the notebook
comes from servers up in the
clouds, not your local machine.
So you can do a lot of data
science and machine learning
without heating up your laptop.
Kaggle also recently
upgraded all their kernels
to have more compute
power and more memory,
as well as extending
the length of time
that you can run a notebook
cell to up to 60 minutes.
But OK.
Enough of me gushing
about Kaggle Kernels.
Let's see what it
actually looks like.
Once we create an
account at Kaggle.com,
we can choose a
dataset that we want
to play with and spin up a
new kernel or notebook in just
a few clicks.
The dataset that we
started in comes preloaded
in the environment
of that kernel,
so there's no need
to deal with pushing
a dataset into that machine
or waiting for large datasets
to copy over a network.
Of course, you can still
load additional files
into the kernel if you want.
In our case, we'll
continue to play
with our fashion
and this dataset.
It's a dataset that contains
10 categories of clothing
and accessory types--
things like pants, bags,
heels, shirts, and so on.
There are 50,000 training
samples and 10,000 evaluation
samples.
Let's explore the dataset
in our Kaggle Kernel.
Looking at the dataset,
it's provided on Kaggle
in the form of CSV files.
The original data was in a 28
by 28 pixel grayscale images
and they've been flattened to
become 784 distinct columns
in the CSV file.
The file also contains
a column representing
the index, 0 through 9,
of that fashion item.
Since the dataset is already
in the environment, in pandas--
this is already loaded--
let's use it to read these CSV
files into panda's data frames.
Now that we've loaded the
data into a data frame,
we can take advantage
of all the features
that this brings,
which we covered
in the previous episode.
We'll display the first
five rows with Head,
and we can run
Describe to learn more
about the structure
of the dataset.
Additionally, it would
be good to visualize
some of these
images so that they
can have more meaning to us than
just rows upon rows of numbers.
Let's use matplotlib to see what
some of these images look like.
Here we'll use the
matplotlib.pyplot library--
typically imported as PLT--
to display the arrays of
pixel values as images.
We can see that these
images, while fuzzy,
are indeed still
recognizable as the clothing
and accessory items
that they claim to be.
I really like that
Kaggle Kernels
lets me visualize my data in
addition to just processing it.
So Kaggle Kernels
allows us to work
in a fully interactive notebook
environment in the browser
with little to no setup.
And I really want to
emphasize that we didn't
have to do any sort of Python
environment configuration
or installation of libraries,
which is really cool.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
Be sure to subscribe
to the channel
to catch future episodes
as they come out.
Now what are you waiting for?
Head on over to Kaggle.com
and sign up for an account
to play with kernels today.
[BEEP]
Though there's no
popcorn in this episode,
I can assure you
that Kaggle Kernels--
[BEEP]
You've got to throw harder.
SPEAKER: That's horrible timing.
[BEEP]
YUFENG GUO: Wait, are
you going to throw
it this way or this way?
[BEEP]
Though there's no
popcorn in this episode,
I can assure you that [LAUGHING]
Kaggle Kernels are popping.